question one computer's depreciating
start at
a certain value and it loses value over
time
right so this is like the flip side of a
compound interest situation
yeah instead of things getting bigger
because we're saving money
things are getting less and less
valuable now we're getting this number
here 648
i deliberately did not ask you guys to
write working here but where does that
number come from
where what are we actually putting into
our calculator to get these numbers
right
the formula yep which is what did we say
it was four
three thousand sorry yep three thousand
and then time
yep uh one minus zero point
four to the power of three okay
fantastic
well done so this is it's our compound
interest formula but for
depreciation we've got this one subtle
difference minus instead of a plus so
things are getting
lower and lower in value this is these
already referred to the fact that even
though it gets given to you as 40
0.4 is probably a better way to
communicate that and
this is just me for your calculator okay
if it looks depressing to you that
you're like what i only had it for three
years how is it worth so little compared
to how much i spent on it
um but buckle up because depreciation is
actually worse than that like for a
computer
it'll lose value even faster than that
right
um and yeah computers they drop value
very quickly okay
because we're subtracting that amount oh
okay good question
are we taking this and then subtracting
or is this the answer how much is the
computer
the formula the formula uh shows
40 minus compounded
okay okay so so just uh just to sort of
get this right
uh strings right um the formula i didn't
actually write this which is a bit
sneaky the formula for compound interest
is a equals and then there's
stuff and i actually did say i was going
to do this last time and forgot sorry
about that
um you know how this is sort of based on
compound interest what's the other kind
of interest
simple i'm not gonna yes
simple interest i don't know if you
remember we didn't dwell on it very much
because it's not as relevant for our
situations everything's pretty much
compounding
but the simple interest formula still
takes principle it still takes a rate
and it still takes
n an amount of time but it's very subtly
different it's not a equals does anyone
remember how it starts
yeah it's i equals p r
n now this gets to sort of what zach was
saying before the simple interest
formula gives you the difference
gives you the interest but the compound
interest formula and therefore the
depreciation
formula which is the same thing but in
reverse it actually gives you the amount
what you end up with not the difference
okay happy with that one is that okay um
let's have a quick look at number three
so i gave you a series what kind of
series is it
it's geometric it has to be geometric
because when they ask this question
what's the uh limiting sum aps
arithmetic progressions don't have
limiting sums right no matter what the
common difference is okay
now you actually have the formula for
limiting sum which gives you 54.
you even have it on your reference sheet
but hopefully it's simple enough that
you guys can remember it what is it
fantastic a over 1 minus r which in this
case i think it's
36 on one minus
a third so you can multiply that through
you get that
you're happy all right now last one just
real quick that we're going to look at
here and then we're going to do some
working for question four because it's
worth looking at it's only what we did
recently
you really had to think about this and
um i i unintentionally threw you a
curveball earlier than i meant to
you're given an ap arithmetic
progression right and then asked to work
out how many terms there are okay
now there's lots of different formulas
that we can use when it comes to all
these
series and sequences and using the right
one
ended up being decisive for a lot of you
because some of you went to like a
formula and you're like i can put stuff
into this but you didn't have all the
pieces
okay bless you i'm gonna suggest that
the place we start
is t of m now why would i go to t of n
rather than s of n t of n is your nth
term
s of n is your sum of the first n terms
right have a look at the information
that's been given to you
you've got some terms 31 44 57 and it
ends at 226
okay now i do not want to use s of n
because
it relies on me knowing what the sum is
and i don't know what the sum is
i could work it out i could just go to
my calculator but that seems like it's
unnecessary work
so i'm going to use this formula for an
ap what is
t of n equal to
x minus 1 times 3 fantastic okay first
term
plus n minus one lots of that common
difference okay
now what we're trying to find is how
many terms there are
which pronoun is that which pronoun
number was that in here
how many terms are there everything it's
it's going to be n right
this is the thing that i don't know okay
but i know
every other pronumeral that's on the
line um for instance i know what a is
it's what is it i can't remember 31 31
um there's my n minus 1. the common
difference is 13.
there's one last piece of information
this was the trickiest one right
where's that other like left hand side
come from
t of n what is that
yeah very good 226 will be my nth term
my last term
okay and then from here it's just some
simple rearrangement it's just some
arithmetic
um do we get do we agree n equals 16
yeah okay fantastic
all right now as promised we're going to
do a bit of working for four but i'm not
going to finish the question out i'm
just going to do enough
that you can get the answer um fix your
hands who got
an answer for question four any answer i
don't care whether it's right or not
just an answer i got an answer but i
know it's wrong okay thank you hands
down
uh you're not the only one seren several
people said to me oh i've got an answer
but it seems wrong it's like 81 000 or
something like that you're like that's
that's definitely wrong
what told you because you didn't you
don't have answers i know you don't
because even i don't have answers i
didn't write anything for this yet
how did you know that was already wrong
81 000.
it's too low it's too low right since
check um it works for seven years what's
the word that tells you there's a single
word that indicates
in the question that it's too low
it's total right so year one year two
year three all the way up to year seven
we've got to include them all okay it's
cumulative thank you that's a good way
to say it so how do we work this out
um you can think about each year's
salary
separately right um what would be the
first uh don't use s because that's
sum let's use a no i'm not even use that
means t is a better way to do it
term one the first salary what is it
80 000. when you have a look at the next
one
after a year so this is the next term
along
right it's going to be that same 80 000
but it's gotten bigger by how much
1.5 percent just like up here i'm going
to try and express that as a decimal
so that'll be one point careful
careful yeah
one 1.015 if you um if you're not sure
about that right think about what
percent means it's division by a hundred
so if you pop one point five divided by
a hundred into your calculator
you'll get the point zero one five that
trails on the end here is that okay
right you got the next one term three
i'm trying to establish a pattern here
right what's it gonna be
eight thousand one point zero
one five squared
i've got three terms and then i'm gonna
say well i'm gonna go all the way to the
seventh year
right i can follow the pattern
it's gonna be 1.015
how many of them six it's one less isn't
it
that's a one less than two okay now i
want the total earnings that's
everything all added up
several of us just worked out this last
one here right
so if i put these all together what kind
of thing do i end up with
i already had one earlier on
it's a geometric series right every term
has shares that common ratio and it's
just getting one bigger one bigger
one bigger i said i wouldn't do the
final working but i do want to remind
you what the
sum of a geometric progression is right
i've got two formulas for it
the one i'm going to suggest that we use
because we're using it a bit is this one
why is this one more appropriate than
the other one
which this guy here this is just off the
reference street
right now apparently the common ratio is
bigger than one
fantastic this is the common ratio here
r i'm trying to avoid negatives yeah
so if i put r into here down the bottom
you can see i'll get something positive
if i did the other one
which has one minus r you're gonna get
negatives is that okay
i'll leave that there and you guys can
go ahead and work out what the answer is